we are going to do a little tribute to
my comer who is the legendary host of
this show and as everybody by now should
know he played a challenge match against
one of the players in the u.s. Junior
close it was held here several weeks ago
he is the US Junior Open champion Kuran
Han and the challenge was that they'll
play a certain variation of the two
Knights defense like an Armageddon game
and the winner well actually I think
that Han had nothing to lose I'm just
Mike put fifty dollars of his own money
and of course it at Armageddon game the
player who gets the white pieces must
play for a win Black has draws so after
a game full of mistakes their game ended
in a draw and Mike had to pay $50 to do
to Han and we are going to analyze this
game first of all make sure that we
cover all of my cameras buoyancy in this
game and his opponents shortcomings a
little bit and then we will see another
game and that second game is going to be
how to do it properly with a recent
example by two top-of-the-line
grandmasters playing the same variation
exactly so without further ado we are
going to go with the game Lee 45 9 f3
knight c6 Bishop c4 Knight f6 I have
heard that mr. camera is very critical
of this move this in itself makes me
roll my eyes a little bit probably one
of the better moves in the position he
tries to refute it with a following
Knight g5 very impressive
a direct attack on f7 and now black has
basically two choices he can play the
gambit Bishop to c5 this is not the
Trexler variation a very crazy line the
intention is if Knight takes f7 Bishop
takes F to check if I had a lecture for
10 hours maybe we can deal with it
however we don't have 10 hours the
correct level would be Bishop takes f7
excuse me I'm coughing I have a cold so
alternatively if he doesn't want to lose
the port on f7 in a real miserable way
and he doesn't want to put this Queen
here like some kids do and take and lose
a lot of material then the alternative
is to play the ambitious move d5 which
is probably the best known in the
position now the white point is attacked
on me for in the bishop on c4 this is
very much resembling the game that I
have shown here to the Sunday class the
cube class but that's not the same game
obviously pawn takes Knight a5 again
like I've mentioned that aforementioned
lecture playing Knight takes d5 and
allowing Knight takes f7 is a very very
dangerous variation after the forced
capture and I go check if you don't want
to lose unite and have lost the right to
cancel and upon your King must come here
and I'm sure that all just players who
have a same mind and a desire to play
chess for fun would not play this
variation because that's just not smart
and not fun after Knight c3 it's just a
huge huge attack so but we go and black
plays the alternative one of many by the
way b4 live in 94 are also playable but
this is a very nice line not a 5
challenging the bishop it is very well
known that before I trust to protect the
bishop let's say d3 then after here here
efore when already block is having a
very very good time here the bishop
looks really funny
I've seen some line where they sacrifice
the piece for the take the pawn in
Sector please but that's a very
speculative continuation in our game
however after 95 he goes Bishop to d3
Bishop to b5 check excuse me I'm ahead
of myself and once again black has a
choice of either committing upon 4 yeah
lucky does in this game or sheepishly
playing the move Bishop d7 I really
don't like Bishop d7 because of the take
stakes
this was a very good trade from blacks
point of view so on we're going to the
game c6 of course we must take taking
with the pawn again I'll repeat what I
said on Sunday
this is a very funny gambit in the sense
that blood gets a funny bone structure a
broken bone structure he has a knight on
the rim
and he is down upon however he gets a
lot of time a lot of Tempe for this and
let's see how that happens first of all
the bishop has to move the game that
I've shown on on Sunday involved the
normal retreat of Bishop to e2 after
which we kick the night away then I'd
get went here we kick it again the
knight must jump here and then black has
several interesting moves to deal with
this night one of where one of which is
Queen d4 or Bishop c5 Bishop d6
in that game that I showed Queen c7 was
played and you should refer to it it's
in the video library of the club and I
think was a very interesting game and
kind of a lesser-known game in our game
however our player plays the move Bishop
to d3 this is kind of a combination of
all the new trying to revive the
variation by putting the Bishop on dot
square and here I'm not a big believer
in this variation even though I've seen
that Kimura plate and when I think that
this is something not just not right
about this line because many times in
this line tonight goes to d5 and f4
then he takes the bishop here and it's
really hard for me to believe that with
this kind of structure White has really
any advantage but some people like it
okay so you can already imagine the time
recommending the move Knight d5 but as
you will see from the game between the
grandmasters it's not the only move you
can play h6 first and then 95 however
after eight six ninety four again 95 and
nine f4 is what I would like to see but
our player who is probably not super
familiar with a variation or at least
wasn't bothered to look at the mainline
he played Bishop e7 okay not my favorite
move again I think that the knight on f6
is simply worth more than the knight on
e4 why because again like I said on d5
he's gonna go to f4 combining some
tickling on the King side and especially
this poor Bishop and the knight on e4
looks impressive right now but when my
f1 goes twice the f5 is gonna go just go
away
stable okay so councils again not the
most accurate nerve in my opinion he
should have taken at the knight on f6
right here this happens very soon but he
should have taken it now and the reason
is once again not to alarm 95 f4 so
castles cost 95 but he just canceled
takes in takes needless to say that with
every even trade that we are witnessing
this actually plays directly into
White's hands because if you could have
snapped his finger and have all the
pieces of the board he is gonna win upon
an end of King and pawn anything that
any child can win against Carlton
because of extra pawn and broken corn
structure there's just nothing from
black so every tray that we do without
purpose is just a step in that direction
of course there's still many steps to be
taken and right now the whole Queen side
looks a little funny now Mike decided to
play the move Knight to c3 okay in
itself a reasonable alternatives not
probably look he won was possible but
okay Knight c3 I came to complain about
c5 I think this move is really early the
idea is clear he wants to use his
useless pawn on the C file to create
some something so right now he wants to
advance it to c4 attack the bishop chase
it away
gain more space put some load on the DMV
pawns and sure enough Mike doesn't
respond to it correctly he played them
with 94 again he wants to trade pieces
in itself like I said not a bad idea
but I don't like the timing of that this
was really a high time to play a move
like let's say maybe b3 to put the
bishop on b2 just stop the pawn from
going to c4 if he goes to c4 I'm just
gonna take it I don't care if you win it
later but this I'll get my Bishop
developed after b3 I'm also have I'd
entertain ideas like Bishop a3 on the
long diagonal all of a sudden this point
can become a little bit passive and in
seeker for help so in any event the game
continued 94 c4 again what was the rush
maybe Bishop e7 first and the point is
dr. Bishop e7 if
trying to play something like b3 or one
of those moves my pawns are starting to
move really fast here again a tempo with
f5 and then maybe four and I'm just
giving a lot of space and a lot of time
so of course I can be too critical
because remember this is an Armageddon
game it's a blood scam it's not a
tournament time condition game so you
have to respect that
so c4 Knight f6 another trade why not
here
Bishop to e4 good tempo rook to b8
of course Bishop to b7 just trades more
pieces so even though the bishop on c8
doesn't look like a charm right now
better off this way now I really didn't
like what Mike did I really think that
he his move is not terrible in itself
but sometimes timing is everything
he went Queen to f3 I believe that in
this position it would have been a lot
more prudent to play once again the move
b3 pawn to d3 this was really a good
move here listen the rook is sitting on
the B 2 square and the bishop on c1
doesn't really know how he's going to
see the light of day let's solve both
problems kill two birds with one stone
b3 and the bishop comes out either to b2
a3 life is not that bad
so Queen f3 and paradoxically what what
I meant to say that this let's say b3
and let's pretend black goes something
like top what really makes no sense
let's see goes Queen e6
and now the idea is to play a 5 now I
can play the move Queen f3 that that I
really like this is a much better move
order than what mike has chosen because
now F I am Bishop d5 is out of the
question
excuse me and I'm gonna threaten to play
Bishop d5 anyways if you go Bishop e7 I
just take it so now the bishop is coming
either to a 3 or B 2 I'm really starting
to like white in that kind of a
structure definitely extra pawn lots of
pieces going getting off the board what
is my problem I don't have any
weaknesses anymore
once I develop my pieces and take the
take care of my be pawn maybe the D pawn
is going to be a bit weak but clearly
white with two bishops is not doing
worse
so in the game he want Queen f3 and
maybe he just underestimated blacks
response because it's very
counterintuitive especially in Lua for
everything that I said to trade pieces
but sometimes under the right
circumstances a good trade is is
warranted and taking the queen is
correct Bishop takes now he thought for
a while and played the move rook e8 okay
I'm not saying that this is a blunder or
anything but I'm I think that Bishop f5
immediately was clearly the best move
developing the last minor you don't know
what this rook belongs maybe you want to
pressure the D pawn I'm not so sure why
their work has to be here I'm sure that
the bishop has to be an f5 like I tell
all my students when you have a choice
between two moves and all things being
equal choose the more flexible one the
one that you are positive about
displacement here the bishop has no
better place than f5 tickling the pawn
on c3 dying to see it move because once
it moves the pawn on d4 is gonna look
really funny so and if it doesn't move
him I just take it so maybe watch this
to place a move like Bishop d1 listen if
I have to play Bishop f5 Bishop do you
want to now it's my move this insertion
of most didn't hurt me one bit I'm quite
happy about it
however rook e8 was played so Luke to e1
Bishop a5 Bishop e4 of course this move
was not possible if the rooks were on f8
and f1 our new opponent for white takes
takes and f5 and now Mike played a
relatively fast move and a mistake a big
mistake he's still really doing okay but
in positions like this and again of
course the shortage of time probably
played a big deal a big part in this
here the question is what to do with the
rook the rook has lots of legal moves it
seems the most logical because rooks are
very clumsy when they are playing from
close he always put one to put the rocks
from a distance it took stuck it's a a
piece that operates well from a distance
but in a situation like this you really
have to respect your opponent's threats
and this Knight that looks really clumsy
now he wants to get revived in other
words he wants to go to c6 and
then visit one of the dog squares like D
for before in lieu of that it was time
to make a decision to play rook III that
would have been a very very strong move
because now if black wants to play 96 he
has to reckon with the move group to c3
and it's not so easy to defend the pawn
on c4 maybe 95 is even forced because
rook before I'm just gonna go a3 and b3
so yeah as you can see here white is a
bit behind development but if I take
another pawn and I'm gonna get my King
closer eventually this is just gonna be
winning so that was very very good
probably 96 is not the most accurate
move maybe has to play rook b c8 or some
some idea king f7 and just not let the
rock wind upon however mike play the
move rook to e1 and now I'm sure that
you already see that after Knight c6 is
in deep trouble he is really in trouble
here because the knight wants to go to
d4 and well it actually got to go to the
fore you will see in a second
things got from bad to worse and of
course the only way to stop it is to
play a move like c3 yeah notice the
crook e3 doesn't work anymore
rook III night here here then if I go
here Chuck and wins the rock so on
exchange rather so not so good probably
the only move to play here is c3 but I
don't have to tell you how ugly this
move looks after pawn c3 the d3 squared
the d2 pawn is backwards the bishop is
stark can't even play b3 I would much
much much rather be black than white in
that position I think black has a
significant advantage
despite his pawn deficit that's not a
good sign so in the game he completely
blundered with b3 and now 90 for a game
over completely this sort of dish if I
had this position that I didn't win in
the next 10 moves I would be really
disappointed in myself because okay what
else do you need it's like your upper
pawn your
to win more stuff it really is beyond
saving and of course Mike was not very
happy with this position this is where
he was starting to make all kinds of
funny noises as you could see in the
video and all kinds of words to the
effect that he's gonna lose $50 yeah so
he played here here rookie - and of
course black I said not only does he
have two points I mean not only did he
get his pawn back but he's also having a
dominating position white is gonna lose
more material for sure I think that I
would have played them of a five here
when I'm looking at this move I'm
thinking how can you not play a move
like this everything is pinned the
bishop is stuck the rook is very passive
more space everything you can dream
about and I'm about to go a four and
this one is gonna really hurt so what he
did wasn't so terrible he took on b3 and
here Mike almost blundered thank God
that this game was not touched moved
because his initial reaction was to play
here after which this move is very
strong I'm attacking two rocks normally
he would play a move like this to kind
of get rid of it but I have my own
interpolation move my only between move
check and yeah very costly lucky for him
it was not touch move and he caught
himself right in time and he took like
this however the position is still lost
so he played 94 again not the only move
but a decent one rookie three f4 he went
back to e1 rook to c8 again I mean this
is this is what the Blitz the blood
stage goes into really serious thumb
trouble it's hard to really be too
critical but there's one point here that
I was really puzzled by he played Bishop
e3 which immediately brings them of 92
into the game that cannot be missed and
desperate cause he's being forked Bishop
on e3 and the rockin e1 he made the move
Bishop to d6
now sometimes you have to ask yourself a
very simple question
okay of course the taking here wasn't
exactly a disaster but why you rookies
attacked by a bishop and that Knight is
attacked by the bishop but by this rook
is attacked by a knight the only
difference is that this night is already
protected and this bishop isn't so all
you have to do is go here now you're
attacking the bishop still attacking the
rock you could win this pawn but I'm
gonna take an exchange I really really
like that kind of deal so even in some
trouble I think that this is strange to
miss in every event he took and Mike
took and takes and takes and takes a
nice bonus pawn all of a sudden from
being a pawn up in the opening because
of the sacrifice all of a sudden he is
down upon and struggling in a row
pending of course this repenting should
have been lost completely I mean a
little technical work but it should have
been lost but somehow Mike manages to
stay alive watch how of course pony five
is safe because would be one is leading
to checkmate and so he went King up one
roof b5 yep knotted there's no mate
let's defend our pawn king e2 kudos to
Mike for choosing the best plan and just
moving forward
finally and king of seven
Kingda Ka fast King e6 not a big blunder
I would have preferred to have played
something like a five so that if King c4
then looked before check tempo then King
e6 but okay you played here here okay
now again got several moves that make
sense in this position and to me it
seems very logical to stay on the excuse
me on the fifth rank because then I can
easily play a five and the pawn will be
protected the rook is guarding my king
my king can just go this way if I feel
like it and the rookie is also attacking
the pawn on detail so if it was me I
would have played here just make sense
okay what he did was he played rook here
and well I mean I suppose king c3 is the
most logical response but my goes to a
decent strategy that
let's trade as many pawns as possible
and he goes d4 not unreasonable I'd say
that this is normal so now this is
forced check King b6 and of course Mike
doesn't want to just lose those two
pawns for nothing so he plays a very
decent move rook air-five I think that I
would have played the move rook here
I'll be very curious to see how my
opponent would respond to move like rook
d5 check is he gonna go this way and
distant himself even more from those
important pawns or he's gonna go the
other way after which I'll check him
again he's gonna have to go to the elf
file if he doesn't want to repeat and
then when I go something like Luke a5
and take this pawn my king and this porn
become really really a factor like I
have said before in the endings class
like the one we have in blader tonight
in the rookie ending the placement of
the pieces is more important than the
number of the points that is really
really true so just to fantasize for a
moment and a non forced variation
something like let's say tipsy let's see
if you go here here here here let's say
it takes and takes and yeah of course
black should win this position but I'm
already seeing chances for white by
playing King up-up or pawn up and this
one can become a little bit of a
headache all of a sudden here you better
calculate so I'm positive that that it
should be winning anyways
so sorry in our game after this you want
here
rook C to check not really necessary but
okay check here here and he took and
rook f7 the only move clearly the only
moon now normally two points against one
should win but in this position it's
very very difficult I think that this is
a hard win because once again the king
and the pawn are can be annoying and the
rook is gonna start giving checks
forever so for now he plays correctly he
keeps those pawns and Mike took and now
he plays here I think this is
a bit hasty I think what he needs to do
is to try to bring the King to support
the pond and later use the rope to go
behind this spawn and prevent it from
Queenie that will be the best strategy
because then the pawns can be so
advanced that at the right time you can
just afford to give up your rope for the
pony very necessary although we can see
that this is far far in the future the
point is not that advanced at all so
okay he goes here check already the king
is a bit limited
needless to say that he should have
played King e7 and if you kept checking
just zigzag this way and come here and
here but he was already in serious Don
trouble and he just overlooked
everything just went here which invites
the check for sure and after here rook
takes and the draw was agreed after this
and this so we can say that even though
he lost yeah played a few more
we considered even though Mike loss is
$50 he put a really valiant defense not
to lose the same game but the opening
definitely leaves a lot to be desired
definitely if we're gonna go back to the
opening one second after here
yeah here I moved like 94 is definitely
a move that should be thought twice B 3
would have been much better and I think
that Mike I would have voted for Mike in
that position because black is some are
really losing the thread so ha ok now we
go on to a different game and I guess we
can call this game how to do it right
you will see an example from the highest
level again same variation exactly
only this time players at a much higher
rating player you could see the player
with the white pieces is a Russian Grand
Master Alexander Ryazan said and black
is Dutch former Bosnian player even
circle of very very strong players
really strong players and this game was
played in 2015 somewhere I think 2014
2014 in the fresh cream lock pretty
recent so II 45 9 f3 knight c6 Bishop
Knight we have the same line same gambit
even the same 86 but now he goes 95 a
much better move the knight wants to go
to f4 as mentioned before and but you
have to pay attention because if you
delay it then some bad things might
happen Cal so now he doesn't play Knight
f4 I'm not sure why I have no idea what
what even was thinking Bishop e7 93 he's
already late all of a sudden and that
one little move developing move and all
of a sudden neither for lost a lot of
its value because neither for I have a
good score on f5 for my Bishop I'm just
going to trade it gana my worries so he
played h5 it's funny that in this
position when I saw them over age five I
thought of myself
that's impossible why would he do that
it looks that he doesn't make sense but
the computer likes it endorses him and
there are some interesting lines behind
the scenes for example somebody might
say why doesn't he just play normal just
like here allowing here and let's say he
would play something like Bishop a6
again this is not a force variation but
just to show you how amazing this line
can become here
here at g6 at first time you think
yourself this is the way to play for
black it looks like a really normal
setup now the bishop would have to
redraw either to h3 which is like really
oblivion because of f5 and efore also he
have f5 and the bishop has to go to
after he black maybe can play g5 it
looks like a really nice position from
black he has lots of space and white his
so behind in development but the tactics
here just murdered the black position
here there's just no hope Bishop takes 8
6 pawn takes Knight takes again you
might look at the position and say wait
a minute why did we SEC apiece I don't
see a mate well look carefully you will
see a mate in a second yeah then the
queen is coming to g4 and this
announcement of pieces of Queen Knight
and Bishop against the King which has no
defenders it's completely hopeless like
if you put this the computer I will bet
that this is even though white is down
the piece probably gonna say that white
is the equivalent of modern a piece up
because I think he's gonna regain the
piece with all the advantages if like
Knight f4 with the intention of coming
here with the night I'm just gonna take
it so for example I see a variation if
here I'm just gonna take and takes and
Queen check Bishop g5 h 4 okay very
unappetizing for blacks point of view
clearly a lost position this is just
losing so this isn't beautiful about
this line for both sides and that is
that there's so much venom in the
position like after castles sorry after
castles Bishop f5 it looks like such an
innocent position but it isn't it really
isn't
those two bishops are hungry looking at
the key side and in a second I'm going
to start developing my pieces in the
meantime is going to take some time to
revive that silly night on a5 and this
night was great here but now if you come
to f4 I might even have a move like d4
you're not attacking my bishop and that
bishop is all over this Knight this is
gonna be really really neat so in any
event so he tries to challenge the light
on g3
playing the move h5 rook e1 white
continues with his plan picking on the e
pawn that's a normal plan in these
positions h4 Knight to f5 so in this
position I'm simply attacking the bishop
on e7 and then the pawn on g7 and of
course it's a bonus to pawn on e5 so
Bishop f6 looks like a forced move here
unless you want to give up the bishop
for the night that would have been
welcomed by white as well we know that
those trades if Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes those trades just in my
favor I'm still attacking the pawn on e5
I have two bishops and I'm about to go
d4 if I want to only white can be happy
in that position
but I think white is already happier
here I think by now having not played
not f4 and allowed this and playing this
h5 r h4 I'm not saying white is winning
but white is definitely for choice here
clearly so Bishop a4 are very very easy
to understand move white wants to
develop his c1 Bishop he doesn't want to
go on this diagonal thinking that it
might just be biting on well if he wants
to play d4 d3 or d4 that's what he wants
to try so black played Bishop e6 d4
so if my camera is watching this video
this is the way to play this opening pay
attention when your opponent doesn't
play 9f for like your opponent hasn't
this is the way to do it put your pieces
on good square go D for now White has
not only the extra pawn but a really
great position all the deficiencies in
the black position such as the pawn and
the night they become really evident
alright so he played Knight to b6 not
not crazy about this move
however after takes takes this is also
nothing to write home about because I'm
about to take you good Bishop I'm also
picking on this pawn in case this Knight
there's any ideas of moving it's not fun
it's really not a fun position what
should he have played instead that's a
really good question
tough to tell maybe ninety seven or
something like that I don't know it's
really really not a place maybe Queen c7
yeah I'm voting for Queen c7 here and
just extra defense against that pawn but
against Queen c7 and we'll just take
this guy and then take this guy again
this only this is just in white favor
white is just having a dream position
here
so he went Knight b6 Bishop d2 instantly
taking advantage of the situation
the bishop is attacking this pawn this
pawn is defended by the knight let's
pick on that night that night is a
little sad now black plays a forced move
Knight B to c4
he has got the defenders Knight and now
he took the knight on 85 again not a bad
move exactly but why not not to play b4
at once miserable after b4 is just 1 0
in my opinion but ok this also wasn't
exactly a sad continuation he took on a5
the 92 car a5 and now he played before
again when you compare this game to the
previous game you really see that white
is doing a tour de force here really an
impressive and impressive array of moves
he just put the screws down and
I wouldn't say black didn't play
anything I mean h4 h5 it for was a
little crazy I agree but this
development and all this dust wasn't
that doesn't seem enough when you think
that the player with the black piece is
a veteran 26:50 Grandmaster 2650 law
like an impressive showing by white so
94 Bishop takes King f8 and now I really
like the mood if he played he took on e5
again why mess up things if you take on
a eight for example and I take with my
queen now this Knight is being harassed
and the pawn is coming to h3 next move
who needs this kind of thing with a
light square bishop and a queen and
along diagonal and this kind of a
development why give chances absolutely
not necessary just greed that just makes
you have to think and be really careful
so he takes e so he had to play here
here and save his rook and save his
bishop at the same time okay why trades
and trades saves his knight Knight to d4
so again instead of just going for an
exchange in speculative position where
you can be attacked and be even more
material up which is not necessary
now I kiss up a ton of pawns and he is
gonna lose one of them probably but he's
just one or two moves away from
consolidating so who cares watch what
happens now Bishop c7 okay after the
pawn here I mean again White uses a very
simple tactic because after Bishop e5 it
might look for a second like well this
is a beautiful diagonal for the doctrine
bishop and the two knights are kind of
hanging this like a skewer at the lock
skewer with lots of meat on that skewer
right here but he just does something
very simple a he gets rid of the first
night by trading how can this be wrong
and takes and then have no illusion this
pin here is just not effective because
he goes rook to d1 again following one
of my more favorable rules that I tell
students and people that are laxatives
and that is when you have a bigger
threat than your opponent you do not
have to respond to his threat that is
something that I really really again and
again because people are young
especially young or new people are very
marek when they have the piece attack
they think of nothing else but move that
piece okay or at least not entering a
variation like this now many times I see
my scholastic players a knight is
attacked somewhere by a pawn and the
hand is already hovering like this over
the night it's like nothing else is
considered just I'm going to move the
knight but where and okay sometimes you
have to move the knight but sometimes
you can attack a rock or a queen or
start an attack and that's ten times
better than just the automatic reaction
now of course the knight is immune
because if Bishop takes Knight rook b8
when the King moves the rook on h8 goes
bye-bye so he needs to do something
about it
he decided to go back with a knight as
good or as bad as any Knight d5 another
little tactical shot of course the
knight cannot be taken for the same
reason a froggie a check very very nice
and yeah in this position it's just a
technical win for white he played King
II 7 releasing his King from jail and
freeing his rook however after Knight
takes a 7y just has lots and lots of
pawns neither 5 he's playing calamari by
inertia I could have resigned
Bishop II 494 King F 1 King F 6 c3
Knight to f5 the knight returns to b5 he
takes this irrelevant pawn on h2 and
white simply played a4 and in this
position a grandmaster at the level of
circle of realizes that this avalanche
of pawns on the a B and C files will
never be stopped never deal of cheaply
and it's time to resign it just a
completely futile and insulting almost
at the Grandmaster level to play watch
how dominating this night is to this
Bishop and my pawn is just gonna go like
a five a-six a-seven a-eight the bishop
is controlling the Queen Square this
Knight cannot even go back easily not
via D section of VI e7 just hopeless so
resigned
okay so the moral of this game is again
with a special emphasis on our beloved
viewer / host my comer is yeah play pay
attention to those games learn from them
be
others can perform better the variation
itself is definitely playable for both
sides very exciting variation but don't
say that it's just completely not for
white because well as this game showed
it isn't